[Music]
so we're going looking at the the uh
grappling from uh Fury day the buried
flowers B now postes used in the
grappling and very similar to those used
for dagger and sword so it suggest it's
a combined system which means it's not
going to be like a modern wrestling
where you're gra you know grappling
clinching and going to the groundw it's
going to be probably more more mobile
and uh avoiding getting stuck so
we're going to look at it from that
perspective and I think when I starting
to look at the postures it sort of shows
that is how it's design okay so there
four postures uh that they're shown two
of them
are kind of transitional
postures well they're all transitional
postures you can move from one to the
other um and two are explicitly postive
where you wait to receive the attack so
the transition
the uh transitional postures are the
forward posture where you're
basically here Reaching
Forward um that's called the uh frontal
posture is the B's tooth which is here
which is kind of like a can be a strike
or it can be a way of
deflecting two that
are receiving postures for one better
word is the long posture
is shown something like this and it's
explicitly says that it's used in the
first
play and the other one is the Iron Gate
which is basically here now
all the other transitional postures
reference to go to Iron Gate iron gate
is a a good receiving posture but it's
also a good posture for breaking things
and dis eting things because the whole
point of this is not
to get into you know a friendly
wrestling match it's to dispose of the
person doing a great deal of damage as
fast as you can so the Iron Gate is
probably the most important posture but
it's not shown in any explicitly anyway
any of the other pictures as they go
through the technique so you have you'd
have to infer it's
there um at the beginning and sometime
and sometimes at the end
okay so the we going look at the first
and second plays so the first
play The Defender starts in uh the
frontal posture and then it looks like
it moves to the ball's tooth and that's
the only picture in the series that has
that so I you know I assume that is that
and then from there it will go to Iron
Gate I mean frontal posture as he comes
in here this is a short movement this is
now against his arm but rolling that
over bringing this out here he's now in
a position I can break his arm here very
easily or I can take him
down this is the third play and he
counters by take his arm away
so as I come over for this he moves this
down this leaves my arm here his legs
here I strike back
in go
[Music]
down okay Fourth Way in this one he
steps forward with his right leg grab
I'm going to start in Iron Gate as he
comes in grab going to take the head
take him down
[Music]
so this is this is the fifth play it
looks kind of sim the third play there's
a there's a grip on the throat as well
I'm going to start in Gate whether
that's correct or not I have no idea but
it seems a good place to start he comes
in grabbing low I go through his throat
grab here grab the throat
[Music]
this the sixth
PL he goes for the grip on the throat
and I
counter pushing his arm up here now
once I get this there's a whole bunch of
stuff I can do I can just take this down
and down here yeah it's kind of up to
your imagination really but that's the
basic of the
move okay so this this is the seventh
play uh it's designed to throw
him onto his head so there's no kind of
easy way of doing this so I'm not going
to actually do the throw I think good
idea uh
I take this uh behind the neck and I
grab
it under his knee now this leg is
straight leg is
bent shift my
post
right
so problem is you got to keep your back
really straight and then just bodily
lift him up here and then keep that
going
crack into the
floor so there's no easy you can't
really half do it without him Landing
quite
heavily okay the eight plays a pressure
point technique it's pressure point just
behind the ear there which is very
painful so he's going for a throw as he
goes for it I push into the pressure
point here this makes him gives him a
bit of a pause from there I can then
going to protect me okay so this is the
counter to the eighth play he pushes up
on the elbow this push up on the elbow
is used four times uh in the whole
sequence so it's quite a common defense
so he's going for the throw I go for the
pressure point he
now brings arm
over this this is the ninth play it's a
grab from behind now that kind of
suggests maybe there's it's not a
oneon-one maybe I'm facing away facing
up you know some there's somebody else
here he comes up behind me and grabs now
when I do this I'm going to try and end
up being the Iron Gate I'm not it's not
just about flipping over it's you know
you need a good solid uh posture at the
end and the Iron Gate gives you that
downward Force as well so grab the from
behind I need to quickly step behind him
here and then turn I don't want to just
turn around this way cuz he'll end up in
my the weakest part of my posture so I
actually want to bring him over and down
more in front of me and if I use the
Iron Gate type
posture Dums
okay so this is uh the 10th play to
throw over the leg but again I don't
really want to bring him
down here because that's a weak part of
the posture so I'm going to try and keep
him more in front of me and uh use the
Iron Gate again uh it says you have to
do this quick because it's a little
bit dangerous if I stay it if I if I
can't do it fast enough he'll throw me
so we both have grapple
I step
behind Okay so this is the 11th play
it's
basically in one ter we call the PA
Nelson H it says leaves the person
defens now all person be defens has to
be somebody else this is another clue
it's not just the one one thing uh so he
he offers no clues about how to get into
it so basically it's up behind the arms
bring brings
forward there now the counter is to find
something
hard push you back into it right smash
the head into uh into a wall or a tree
or a
PO okay this is the 12th play and it's
the uh the classic of knee to the groin
so he comes to grab i knee him in the
groin okay to counter that he's going to
grab my
leg to the
[Music]
ground is the 13th PL
so it uses the frontal
posture here so he sees sees me around
the
waist basically
stick both hands in his face now a
counter to that is he he lifts my
elbow okay this the 14th play so it's a
counter to the 13th play he seizes my
waist I slam into his face now he then
moves back takes my leg
push this is the 15th Place again uses
the frontal posture it's grabbing around
my neck I come over and
slap from here I can go into the third
place all right take down
there you can counter that
by pushing up on my
elbow okay this final play is uh count
as the previous play so he's grabbing
around the neck nice slaming his face
and just comes up underneath this his
thumbs in my ey now to cter
that push his elbow up bring him
into okay so that was the Fior wrestling
uh kind of frustratingly he talks a lot
about locks and binds and taking people
into help but never shows any of it
it'sit of a sort of a gaping hole in the
in the whole thing really she's a bit of
bit of a shame I don't know why it's
missing but that's the way it is so you
just have to work what we got